I just stay in my lane like this is back
to self-awareness I stay in my lane I'm
a Salesman I'm a business builder I've
done it my whole life I was an F student
at 13 and 14 my friend's parents told my
friends not to hang out with me because
I was a loser I'm more successful than
my entire graduating class combined like
like this is because the market doesn't
understand that people don't get it you
have to double down on your strengths
and you have to Punk your weaknesses in
America there's billions of dollars made
on selling you how to fix the things
that you're not good at it's a huge
mistake you need to figure out who you
are and go all-in that's what I did and
so when you talk about business or
marketing when you talk about the New
York Jets and when you talk about wine
I've got nothing but bravado everything
else you should see me sitting around
dinner tables right now talking about
politics the level of humility and the
level of listening you wouldn't expect
from me because that's not how you're
used to consuming me I'm loud and proud
because I only stay in my lane take very
close attention I've got nine years of
content on the internet now maybe a
little bit more I've stayed very very
very narrow for me it's lucky the reason
I've been able to kind of grow is my
narrow thing is consumer behavior which
I can deploy against anything so my
marrow thing happens to be quite wide
which allows me to play it allows me be
a good investor it allows me to run
businesses and allows me to be a
personal brick-like
it allows you to do things but I don't
leave it from
[Music]
you